looky with your phone hola
I just see myself hello there I'm on
Choi the buildin I'm about to interview
myself how's it going kind of weird
good let's go okay let's go what was the
first thing you ever bought with a
paycheck for being a musician
[Music]
next one have you got any songs that
always get stuck in your head on repeat
any songs that get inside my head are
boy and their spouse eat [ __ ] another
Spade say I agree if I hear this song
one more time I would go to jail for
life just for that
yep like a ring worst song ever sorry -
whoever made it it's probably a nice
present most of us how do you know him
what's the best thing about being famous
for me nothing my famous yeah do you
have a specific a creative process when
you are writing music lyrics I smoke a
spliff maybe two maybe three four maybe
full get into the vibe you know
sometimes are bright stuff based on the
conversation that I'm having so are you
gonna about this conversation here yeah
why not I think you're pretty cool yeah
you're pretty cool do you think I'm cool
I'm cool as well perfect if you could be
a superhero what would your superpower
be and why I'm not gonna allow that to
be Hulk why come love to be Hulk why
there's not really an explanation for
being hope you just get angry and that's
it I wish I could go whole [ __ ] hits the
fan you were to put a fan here yeah and
I wanted to sit on top of it while it's
it this [ __ ] it's game over isn't it I
agree sometimes it's good to lose
control you're not would you want to
lose control till extend obviously don't
want to murder anyone I don't want to be
green as well that's a bit weird
next question please what's your
favorite book I'm into like Russian
novels those kids being stuck my life
you wouldn't explain that for me which
is yes I was no next question what was
the highest point of your career so far
the best bit of my career is going
onstage and seeing everyone vibe with my
[ __ ] I'm allowed to say [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] the highlight of my career is every
time I performance for any people that
listen to me and that support me so you
know keep it humble it's question what
advice would you give to those starting
out in the UK rap music industry hmm you
say please don't stop that's the main
thing everyone just feels like they just
need to give up because they never got
their million views in 24 hours to [ __ ]
down since you know I'm trying to say
the main factor of the whole thing is
just not giving up that's the main thing
very good answer
hard work is important enough it's just
gonna make you go downhill and you know
that's all [ __ ] I was going to the
studio every day yeah I'm with you every
day so I'm [ __ ] nervous so I don't
even know where the [ __ ] I'm asking you
all these [ __ ] questions or [ __ ]
tired of seeing your face this is the
last question how does that make you
feel young sir upset not sure if I could
say the same
where do you see yourself at this one as
long as I'm healthy I really don't
because as long as we're healthy you can
give a [ __ ] about your [ __ ] who do I
[Music]
just see myself
differences of a [ __ ] sake man perfectly
matched one day on there'll be Easter
come beetle
you